[Music]
Kendall Square is a hub of science
technology and innovation and at its
heart is an opportunity
the Volpe center 14 acres of unused
space largely cut off from the community
building on input from Cambridge
residents and the city's extensive urban
planning efforts MIT has developed a
plan to transform the space and
revitalize the area it's a plan that
calls for connecting neighborhoods to
new open spaces designed for recreation
and relaxation creating new pedestrian
links from residential areas to the
river constructing new housing to create
strong and affordable local community
establishing a community center with
space for entertainment as well as
educational and cultural activities
installing retail stores and restaurants
many locally owned catering to diverse
audiences and income and building lab
and office space so innovators continue
to create the future right here in
Cambridge it's a plan that calls for a
dynamic new neighborhood where all are
welcome a place where everyone can
participate in mi t--'s mission to build
a better world and our shared mission to
build a better community
[Music]